I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. I hope you're in a festive mood today because we're talking about Moroccan Christmas. So get out your Christmas plaid, but put away that nativity scene because Phyllis is going to throw you the party of a lifetime. She sure is. It's season five, episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Paul Feig. Here is your summary. As you said, Phyllis
0|||I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. I hope you're in a festive mood today because we're talking about Moroccan Christmas. So get out your Christmas plaid, but put away that nativity scene because Phyllis is going to throw you the party of a lifetime. She sure is. It's season five, episode 11, written by Justin Spitzer and directed by Paul Feig. Here is your summary. As you said, Phyllis
throws a Moroccan-themed Christmas party, which receives compliments from the majority of the group, but some serious contempt from Angela. Oh, she is not happy. Dwight runs a black market doll trade out of The Office, and Meredith gets wasted and sets herself on fire. That's a doozy of a sentence. It's quite a work party. Michael decides to hold an intervention demanding Meredith get help for her alcoholism and then talk about a doozy of a work party. Phyllis spills the beans about Angela and Dwight in front of everyone. Everyone. She announces it to the whole bullpen. Except Andy. Oh, Andy. Yeah. Andy and a sitar. His goodbye as he's leaving broke my heart. We're getting ahead. We're getting
ahead. We're getting ahead. All right. Fast fact number one. This was the third Christmas themed episode of The Office. Yes, it was. Season five, but only three Christmas episodes. Why? Well, the first season we didn't have one. And then in season four, it was the writer's strike. I know. We missed a Christmas party. It has been two years since we had a Christmas party on The Office. They were always some of my favorite episodes, so I was excited. Me too. I liked them because they were majority group scenes. Yes. We were all together all the time. It was like a whole episode of conference room. So lots of bits. Lots of bits. Lots of laughing. We would just have the best time. We would get loopy. We
would. But in the best way. Fast fact number two. The inspiration for this episode. I was able to get in touch with writer Justin Spitzer. What Justin have to say? He told me that they had had these two ideas rolling around for a really long time. The first one was the idea of a Moroccan Christmas. They just loved the idea that Phyllis had thrown that amazing goodbye party for Toby and that maybe the success had gone to her head a little bit. And she's going to go big. Big theme. Yes. They loved that this would piss Angela off. So this was like one card, right? You know what the card probably said? What? Phyllis happy Angela pissed. Christmas. Question mark. Why is your character always so angry on Christmas?
She's angry all the time. But it really comes out at the holidays. I tell you. She has levels of anger. Sometimes she's like suspicious bitch. Sometimes she's happy bitch. Sometimes she's sad bitch. And then Christmas bitch is a whole different bitch. Oh boy. Buckle in for Christmas bitch. Okay. So the other card that they had on the wall for a really long time said Meredith intervention. Okay. So they decided to marry these two ideas. Remember when they did like Michael has to fire someone on Halloween while we're all dressed up? Yeah. It's the same thing. Yes. Exactly. Justin said that a holiday party also seemed like a really good place for Meredith to drink too much and set her hair on fire. Like there could
be this sort of rock bottoming moment. Right. And it's an event. It's like a big event and everyone's there to witness it. Yes. Fast fact number three. I have a talking head observation for this episode. Oh, I'm so curious. So as you rewatch this episode, take a note of the talking heads. Almost all of them are filmed from different angles than we normally would. I believe there's only one where someone's seated in the traditional chair with the kind of party through the right. Right. Right. We're all over the office. All over the office. So this was not just because there was a party happening behind us. Justin said this was because they wanted to wait until they were in the editing room to place the talking heads
throughout the episode. And they didn't want anything in the background to like in some way mess up their ability to move these talking heads around. Well, they had probably learned their lesson from that episode weight loss. Yeah. Where they had to digitally, it's hard word to say, they had to digitally change Ed's tie and shirt because they kept moving the talking heads and what was happening behind them didn't match. Yeah. So you'll notice even Michael's talking heads, he is not seated at his desk. He's standing in front of his desk and they purposely framed out the window behind him because timing wise, they didn't know if it would be like still daytime or if it would be evening. So they really tried
to make all the talking heads as totally neutral as possible. Smart. Yeah. And it was kind of fun after Justin told me that I went back and rewatch the episode and it was totally true. Yeah. I read the shooting draft and definitely things are moved all around. So it's good they did it. Yeah. That's all I got. Well, before we get into this episode, I went digging in my digital clutter. Okay. And I found an email from Paul Feig that on December 11th, 2008, he emailed the group Jenna and invited us all to a Christmas taco party to watch the Moroccan Christmas episode at his house. Oh. And he said, I know, I know, Morocco and tacos make no sense, except they do kind of rhyme and we have a really great
taco cart that we want to use. And we all went over to his house December 11th, 2008 and watched Moroccan Christmas together. I love that you brought that up because Paul and Laurie Feig used to host so many viewing parties at their house and they were just the most wonderful hosts and I'll never forget he had that screen that you come down from the ceiling. So he had like a very normal looking living room. Yeah. Cozy. Like a place you'd read books. I believe there was like a green leather chair. Oh yeah, there was like cozy chairs with like a blanket draped over it. So cozy. And then all of a sudden when it was time to watch the show, the screen would come down out of the ceiling and it
would turn into this amazing viewing experience. I thought these guys are doing it right. They know what they're doing. Yeah. And they have a great taco cart. That's so cool. Well, there you go. Just a little something from my digital clutter. And now we should break down this episode. Well, I think we should take a break first. And now we should take a break. Let's do it and we'll be back to talk all things Moroccan Christmas. Well, we are back and wow, is Dwight's desk festive or what? Oh my, this is an epic prank by Jim. Every single thing on Dwight's desk is wrapped in Christmas wrapping paper, including his chair. Yeah. When did Jim do this? How long did it take? What the heck? I have so
much to share about this. Oh, go. All right. First of all, Justin Spitzer told me this was his idea. This was his pitch. He said that he was always talking to his friends who worked in the corporate world. And he would ask them what sort of pranks go on in your office. Because I think at a certain point, it started to stress out the writers that they had to come up with these Jim Dwight pranks. So they were always fishing. Tell me a prank. I need an office prank. He said that the single most mentioned prank was this idea of wrapping someone's desk in paper or aluminum foil. So Justin pitched this idea. We got so much mail from people asking, how did we pull this off? I reached out to Randy
Cordray. Oh, Randy. He shared all the details. Of course he did. And then he probably did a deep dive for you on something random. He did. Okay. So first of all, he said there was a note in the script that did not make it into the episode. And it was a Jim talking head. And here's how it went. Jim says, actually, it took me about a week to recreate the desk and chair in chicken wire. I had to come in about four hours early and set it all up. And I think I pulled something in my back dragging Dwight's real desk all the way up to the roof. All for a three second payoff. Totally worth it. I read that too. And I was like, why, why do you have to take the desk up to the roof? Why couldn't you just stash
it in the warehouse? I swear I remember us filming a tag of Dwight working up on the roof. Oh my gosh. I swear we did. I can't confirm it. But I feel like I remember what, you know, you're walking from your trailer to hair and makeup and you're like, why are they putting a desk on the roof? I have a hazy memory of this. What else did Randy say? All right. So Randy also said that Greg Daniels was pretty insistent that the gag desk be made out of chicken wire because that's what it said in the script. Oh, and he wanted it exactly like that. Yeah. Because we'd sort of, Jim has this whole speech. He's like, it needs to reflect what Jim said. But chicken wire is stronger than you think. Oh, yes,
it is. Right. It wouldn't have collapsed. Nope. It wouldn't have Vange. Did they make one with chicken wire and it didn't work? Yes. Oh my gosh. So Randy said that he and Paul Feig and our set designer, Michael Gallenberg and our first AD, Kelly Cantley all tried to talk Greg out of this. They were very skeptical it would work. But Greg really needed to see it for himself. Okay. So here's what they did. They built four different desks out of four different materials. Oh my gosh. What were the materials? One of them was chicken wire. Okay. One was styrofoam. One was balsa wood. What? And one was corrugated cardboard. And then they meticulously gift wrapped all of them. Oh, oh, can I guess? Can I guess
which one worked the best? Yeah. What do you guys think? I wish we could hear what you think out there. I think the cardboard. The corrugated cardboard. That's what I would bet on. All right. At the end, I'll tell you which one it was. Okay. Okay. So they set up one of the desks. Yeah. And then they asked our stand-in, Stephen Socks, to come in and do Dwight's motion of walking in, setting the briefcase down and sitting down to see what would happen. Now, there's four different types of desks and four different types of chairs. Yes. Wow. And Stephen is going to try each one while all these people watch him. Oh my gosh. Would you do it work today, hon? Well, I sat on a faking desk made out
of Christmas wrapping. I have to say, I was fascinated by the backstory of this because as actors, we just showed up. There was a wrapped desk. We did the scene. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. This was like, look at all the prep that went into this one little bit. Oh my gosh. Also, I was so fascinated by this idea of being a tester that I reached out to Stephen Socks to ask him, what was this day like for you? And lady, he sent in an audio clip. Oh my God. Amazing. We have to hear it. Okay. Play it. I vividly remember this test. I didn't do a lot of tests like this. So it really stands out. I think we were all excited to see this cold open, you know, come to be because it read so funny in the script. But I think
we have to remember the pressure that, that you have trying to make something like this a reality. You know, the whole idea probably seemed kind of easy on paper, but it was really up to the set designer, Michael Gallenberg and his team to make it a reality. Like I said, I would do, I would do tests, but they were mainly hair and makeup tests or, you know, a lot of camera tests, but I don't remember one quite like this. So I walk into the bullpen and there's a lot of people there. Greg Daniels was there, the director Paul Feig, Randy Cordray, our first assistant director, Kelly Cantley, of course, Michael Gallenberg and then Phil Shea and the prop department as well. And what I saw was just like what
you see in the episode, it just looked like a desk wrapped in wrapping paper. But as soon as I walked in, it was made clear to me that I should not touch the desk, like don't really go near the desk until we're going to do the test. I mean, specific instructions and it was told to everybody that to just keep clear of the desk, don't touch this thing. It was there like their only prototype. And so I kind of imagined underneath the wrapping paper, like it was some kind of house of cards or something just ready to ready to fall. So I didn't even want to like breathe on it because I just was thinking in my mind, what if I knock this thing over and find everybody before we even do the test? I mean, that would
have been like a total nightmare. But then they were ready to do it. And props department gave me the briefcase, which had something inside of it in order to give it some weight. And so they said go so I threw the briefcase on the desk sat in the chair and I totally expected that I would fall like right to the ground. But to be honest, the chair felt kind of like a like a regular office chair, maybe like an old office chair that kind of semi reclined and collapsed a little, but it still was fully supporting me and the desk just kind of bent a little bit. It looked like a saggy like rope bridge or something with the briefcase on top of it. But obviously there was major disappointment in the room.
I mean, just everyone looked at it with just such disappointment and the air just kind of like left the room. And being the only one there that didn't really know it was everything that was going on. I kind of felt like I had messed up or something. So it was very awkward moment. So I got up off the chair and I remember standing next to Michael Gallenberg and kind of put my hand to my chin and looking at the props that didn't work and just kind of go that didn't work. Oh, that's too bad, you know, like, trying to fit in. And so it was very memorable moment. But then they brought another desk out like a few minutes later, they had everyone leave so they could reset. And this one is the one that worked. It's the prototype
that ended up making it as the final one. And it just collapsed. I mean, I hit the ground pretty hard. And it kind of surprised me because of the first one and how it was made. But it was pretty memorable. Isn't that such a fascinating like look into behind the scenes of making a show? Yeah. I mean, we obviously weren't there that day, right? Right. So we had no idea all of these desks being made and all of these like test runs and Stephen, oh my gosh. So Randy said that the desk that worked was made out of styrofoam. Oh, dang it. But here's the thing, it sounds like they only did two tests. They did chicken wire, didn't work, they did styrofoam,
it worked. So they stopped. Yeah. So lady, maybe the corrugated cardboard would have worked. We don't know. Okay. Okay. You could be right. I could be right. But boy, the styrofoam, man, it went down. And then finally, Randy told me when it was time to shoot, they made three desks out of the styrofoam that they had ready to go. But that rain nailed it on the first take. So we didn't even need any of the other backups. It was a one taker. It's amazing. Well, Phil Shea was really busy this episode. He had to make so many props. The desk obviously was the biggest one. Oh yeah. But we have more to share. Princess unicorn. Princess unicorn,
but there's more. Oh, what else? Oh, you've got a whole thing. I've got some stuff. Oh, good stuff. All right, let's get into the episode. All that was just the cold open. I know. Well, the episode starts with you really are getting a view of the bullpen and how it's decorated. Phyllis is going around and sort of doing last touches, right? Yes. Where did the budget for this come from? I say she dug into some Bob Vance cash because this is an over the top party. Oh, that is such a good point, Angela. Well, she has a talking head that she says the theme for her Christmas party is called Knights in Morocco. I love a party with a theme. I know. I get really excited. I mean, my 15th birthday,
my theme was hummingbirds and we all painted hummingbirds and I had little pink hummingbirds like garland hanging in the bushes. It was amazing. I love a theme. Well, Phyllis does too. And did you notice that Phyllis has on brand new glasses for this episode? No. Yes. And we talked about it in the DVD commentary and Kate said, and do you remember they were called her power glasses? What? I know. And because Phyllis is like the head of the PPC, she's like a boss lady. They wanted her look to reflect that. Oh, I love this detail. Yes. And Phil Shea brought a bunch of glasses to Phyllis. They picked out this particular pair and they even put her prescription in them. So Phyllis and her power glasses are going
to take Angela to task. Well, her standoff with Angela starts right away. She marches over to Angela's desk and she just zeros right in on that nativity scene. Yeah. And she like just sweeps half of it into the drawer. Baby Jesus went into the drawer. Sure did. Angela's not happy. I have a background catch at one minute and 50 seconds. Did you see what was on the dry erase board? It was fuzzy. Okay. Well, I zoomed in on it and this was so fascinating to me on the calendar. It says December 10th, copier maintenance, which just made me laugh so hard because the office got new chairs, but that same old copier still there. And then it said on December 23rd, the warehouse is closed. And at noon on December 24th, Dundramiflin
closes and the party starts at one. So we're having a party on Christmas Eve at one o'clock? That's what it said on the dry erase board. So I was like, what the heck? Everyone's there on Christmas Eve. So later in the episode, when Michael is dragging Meredith into a rehab center, it's Christmas Eve. According to the dry erase board. I don't know if that's what the writers intended, but that really got me tickled. And I have a bone to pick with Phyllis. Oh, because Phyllis says that Angela's nativity scene is not on theme. It's not Knights of Morocco. Right. Well, what about the fact that Michael has on his Christmas tie that he has worn every single Christmas? Mm hmm. Right. Pam has on a pin on her sweater
of Santa. Oh, Phyllis has a little wreath on her jacket. So I feel like Phyllis is singling Angela out. I think all that evidence is really good. I also think it's really obvious that she's singling Angela out. I think the entire party was thrown to piss off Angela. I know, I know. And then these little details, I guess, are just little jabs, little digs. I mean, she makes Angela get rid of the Christmas tree. Oh, lady. All right, I have to share about this because in the episode, it's like three seconds, right? Yeah. This was a huge scene. This was like multiple location scenes, you guys. It took like a half of a day. What? Yes. In the script. And we actually did film this and it's in deleted scenes. Angela Martin
goes over to the tree. It's double her size. And she has to drag it through the bullpen. Lady, I tripped over those pillows on the floor. Uh huh. And the tree fell on my head. What? I fell to the ground. The tree fell on top of me. Then I had to drag it down the stairwell. This Christmas tree out the building through the parking lot, all the way to the street. We filmed all of that. It legitimately was a physical workout. I actually like messed up my hair. I had like scratches on like my hands from the tree trying to grip it. None of it's in the episode. It's in the deleted scenes. And what was great is over all of this action were two talking heads, one Angela and one Phyllis. Can you play those? I do
not mind doing hard labor. Ronald Reagan got his start as a stock boy lugging heavy boxes 10 hours a day. And he went on to become the president of a party planning committee. I like to call the United States of America and most people call it that. Did you know that an aunt can carry five times its own weight? All it needs is a strong queen to tell it what to do. And there's nothing that little creature can't accomplish. Phyllis, fast. Oh, Phyllis and her power glasses and some serious sass. Yes, that muffled sound in between was me like falling down the staircase with the Christmas tree. Were you so bummed when you watched the episode and it was cut out? I was so bummed because I thought it was hilarious.
And that talking head I do about Ronald Reagan, my hair is all messed up. All right, so Phyllshay has tackled a Styrofoam desk chair, all objects wrapped in Christmas wrapping. He's also found Phyllis a pair of power glasses. Phyllshay's next project would have been Princess Unicorn. Yes. Dwight enters with a stack of boxes. And he explains that each year he researches the most popular toy of the holiday season. He buys as much of it as he can. And then as parents become more desperate, he sells them at a profit. It's a little bit genius. We got a lot of mail asking about this Princess Unicorn storyline. Okay. Where to begin? First of all, this was a collaboration of several writers. Justin said that they had
originally written a different story for Dwight and at the last minute they wanted to change it. And they had a new writer who had just started on the show that week named Halstead Sullivan. This was his pitch. Halstead. Amazing. Crushing it in his first week on the job. We were able to get in touch with Halstead. He confirmed, yes, that he pitched this idea of Dwight having a side hustle of buying up these holiday toys and selling them at a profit. Halstead said that he and writer Aaron Scher were sent into a room to figure out what this toy should be. Aaron said, well, kids love princesses and unicorns. How about a Princess Unicorn doll?
I love this kind of collaboration. So you have Halstead saying, we need the story of the toy and he sells the toys. And then Aaron is like, what about a unicorn and a doll collide? Yes. Then Halstead came up with the catch phrase, my horn can pierce the sky. Halstead, are you kidding me? Right. That was you. That stuck in our heads forever. Forever. Do you remember that, Jenna? But we sang it all week. We have to hear Michael sing it. My horn can pierce the sky. And then Jenna, when I listened to the DVD commentary, immediately Kate and I sang it.
What? My horn can pierce the sky. Thank you, Halstead. Well, you know, they made a whole commercial for this doll. I know. With a little girl and a jingle at the end. It was crazy. What else did they say about it? They said actually before settling on this idea, there was an alternate idea called Hank Grenade. This was a doll that when you threw it, his arms blew off. That was Hank Grenade.
But they settled on Princess Unicorn. So once that was settled, there was a lot of discussion over what she should look like. Was she a human princess with unicorn features? Was she more of a horse with a human face? I guess they went around and around. And in the end, Phil Shea had to make this princess unicorn doll. Shanti told me that Phil actually used a team of designers and toy makers. Oh my gosh. And they had to come up with a design that would not infringe on anyone else's design because I guess toys in general and dolls specifically are very tightly controlled by the manufacturers. Right.
For their intellectual property rights. Yeah. It can't look like anything else. Yes. And they actually had to go through the NBC Universal Legal Team to make sure that they had met all the requirements of a specifically unique doll toy. That is how we came to have a princess unicorn. Amazing. Yeah. Wow.
Phil Shea was so busy this episode. So busy. Oh my gosh. When we would see him running through the parking lot, this is why. I don't know how he did it. I know. Well, the party's underway now. It's getting going. There's cocktails. Jim and Pam have this flirty moment with like he's rubbing the lamp for wishes. Well this scene made me curious and I had also been watching the bloopers and there is this
moment between Ed and John and the bloopers that never made it into the episode. That's kind of weird where Jim is looking at this coffee mug that Andy made. Okay. I was like, what is the thing? What are they? What are Jim and Pam doing? So I was very curious about these scenes and I went to the script and in the shooting draft, there is a Jim and Pam side by side talking head where they share that they are in a real financial bind. Oh.
Yeah. And they have agreed not to buy each other anything for Christmas but instead will be taking items from the Dunder Mifflin office to give to each other. Whoa. So yeah, there were all these little scenes of you guys like showing each other different items around the office and then there was a whole scene where you ultimately decided on something and gave each other gifts. What did I get? I don't remember any of this.
Wait, before I tell you what you got, can I just tell you some of the moments in the side by side talking head that I couldn't believe? Yes. All right. Jim shares that money is tight because of the closing fees on the house that he bought. Okay. Pam shares. Get ready. Pam says, my credit's so bad. I'm hoping someone steals my identity. They couldn't handle my finances worse than me.
Oh no. Okay. Oops. Yeah. And Jim says, it's okay. We've decided not to spend any more. Any money on presents this year? The rule is the gift has to be something from inside the office. Okay. And Pam says, so in addition to the party, we're going to spend the day shopping. And
if anyone's interested, my social security number is 793-476882. Isn't that hilarious? Yes. What is Pam's running up her credit on? I don't know. I know. What is Pam buying? Maybe she charged all of art school. Just put it all on her card. Maybe she did. Well, do you want to hear what they gave each other?
Yeah. What did I get? After a whole party of them looking at items in the office. Okay. To, I guess, steal? I don't know. What is their life of crime together? All right. At the end of the day, Pam hands Jim a gift wrapped in copier paper and he opens it up and it's a pair of sunglasses that she has made out of paper clips and brown plastic from a folder. Wow.
So wait, Phil Shea had to make that too? Yes. He had to make sunglasses made out of paper clips and brown plastic. And Jim's like sunglasses and they even have little pads for my nose. They had little erasers where the nose would go. I have to stop you. Is this in the deleted scenes? Can you screen grab these sunglasses and put them on the pod?
No, it's not. Oh. No. That's a tragedy. No, I know because you know they exist somewhere. Pam says it took me hours to make them. Wow. But don't use them outside because there's no UV protection. Okay.
And then Jim hands her a box and she opens it to reveal a beautiful dainty watch. And she's like, wait, you didn't make this. You bought it. No fair. And Jim says, okay, here's the thing. Technically I had this in the office. I bought it for you three years ago, but it was way too big and I chickened out. And Pam says, yeah, it kind of screams I love you. And Jim's like, do you like it? And she says, I love it. Wait, was that the year you gave me rocks? Jim says, wishing rocks also romantic. Oh my gosh, I love this. So you and John had this whole storyline that was playing out in the background that ended
in the scene and it didn't make it in. Do you want to hear something crazy? While I was prepping Moroccan Christmas, I was cleaning out my desk at home and I found the teapot note. Oh, good Lord. Are you kidding? I found it. The actual note. The note that John gave me at the end. Oh my gosh.
The envelope says Pam and it's a little Christmas card. It was in with like all of my like stationery and stuff, right? I'm like going through my stationery and I'm like, what's this? What's this card that says Pam? I opened it up and I was like, it's the teapot note. I love that that's what you found. Is that crazy? Yeah, it is crazy. But you know what's so perfect is when I cleaned out my desk, if you remember, yeah, I found, this was like years ago, I found Dwight and Angela's like sex contract punch card.
Oh boy, our characters had different stories, different journeys. Okay. All right. So I had to share that because I thought that was a wonderful Jim Pam thing that didn't get to be in the episode. But now we really need to talk about these drinks that Michael is making for Meredith. The first drink Michael makes Meredith, he calls it a one of everything. It's equal part scotch, absinthe, rum, gin, vermouth, triple sec, and two packs of Splenda. Now isn't some of this drink a Long Island iced tea minus the Splenda? I don't know.
Am I wrong? I don't know what's in Long Island iced tea. I just know it's like seven liquors. Yeah. Well, yeah. Well, Meredith thinks this is the best thing she's ever had in her life. Oh yeah. Then Michael makes Jim a drink with vodka and orange juice. Not a screwdriver guys. It's called a orange vodka. Yeah. It rolls off the tongue. It does. There was an alt in the script. Okay. In the script, Michael makes Jim a drink with Jack Daniels and just regular Coca-Cola.
我错了吗？我不知道长岛冰茶里有什么。我只知道它大概有七种烈酒。对。好吧，是的。总之，梅瑞狄斯觉得这是她这辈子喝过最好喝的东西。哦，对。然后迈克尔给吉姆调了一杯加伏特加和橙汁的饮料。这不是螺丝起子，伙计们。这叫橙味伏特加。对。这名字真顺口。确实顺口。剧本里原本有一个备选。好吧。在剧本里，迈克尔给吉姆调了一杯加杰克丹尼和普通可口可乐的饮料。
And he calls it a Coke Daniels. And Kate shared that in one scene with Steve, they were improvising. Okay. Steve was making up all these drinks and Steve improvised sangria with peppermint schnapps and Kate improvised, let's call it sex on the couch. And Steve as Michael was like, ew, but that didn't make it in. And then Kate also shared, are you ready for this? He hands her a drink in one take. She takes a big swig and goes, oh my God, you guys, there's real booze in that. They had forgotten to empty out one of the bottles because they would empty out the liquor bottles
他管这叫可乐丹尼。凯特分享说，在和史蒂夫拍的一场戏里，他们是在即兴发挥。好吧。史蒂夫编出了所有这些酒，史蒂夫即兴发挥了薄荷烈酒桑格利亚汽酒，而凯特即兴发挥了——我们叫它“沙发上的性爱”吧。史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔当时反应是，额，但这没有被剪进正片里。然后凯特还分享说，你准备好听这个了吗？他在一条过里递给她一杯饮料。她猛喝了一大口，然后说，哦，天哪，伙计们，这里面有真酒！他们忘了倒掉其中一个瓶子里的酒，因为他们会把烈酒瓶子倒空，
and put just water or iced tea. And they had missed one. And they gave Kate a drink with actual booze in it. She was like, guys, that's booze. Oh no. I mean, she only took one swig. You know what I mean? But still. But still. What a shocker. I know.
然后只装上水或冰茶。结果他们漏掉了一个。他们给凯特喝的那杯里有真酒。她当时说，伙计们，这是酒。哦，不。我的意思是，她只喝了一大口。你知道我的意思吧？但还是……但还是。真是个大惊吓。我懂。
Oh. Also during this setup of the party, I want to point out, this episode had a lot of shots that were just like little moments, right? It really reminded me of some of our early episodes where we had these, what did we use to call those? Just these little vignettes in the background. Yeah. Those little moments that the B camera would get that really filled in the whole picture. It really reminds me of the first two seasons.
哦。另外在派对的这个筹备阶段，我想指出的是，这一集有很多镜头只是那种小小的片刻，对吧？这真的让我想起我们早期的某些集，当时我们有这些——我们以前叫它们什么来着？就是背景里的这些小情景。对。B组摄像机拍到的那些小瞬间，真的让整个画面更加饱满。这真的让我想起前两季。
Same. Well, during this kind of montage of filling out the party and what's going on, you know, Ed as Andy is playing the sitar. Yes. We got a lot of mail about it. Izzy T, Liam D, and Grant S all wrote in to ask, does Ed Helms really play the sitar? No. Not before this episode, he didn't. But he's such a badass that he just picked it right up. Yeah.
我也是。好吧，在派对布置和情况介绍的这个蒙太奇期间，你知道的，埃德扮演的安迪在弹西塔尔琴。是的。我们收到了很多关于这事的邮件。伊兹·T、利亚姆·D和格兰特·S都写信来问，埃德·赫尔姆斯真的会弹西塔尔琴吗？不会。在这集之前他不会。但他太牛了，居然直接上手学会了。对。
So you guys probably know that Ed plays guitar. He plays banjo. Randy told me that previously in his career, he had produced a different show where they needed an actor to play a song on the sitar. And this actor was also a guitar player, but he was told that the sitar is a very difficult instrument to play. It's very difficult to tune properly. And that in that instance on that other show, he had to hire a tutor and allow about four weeks of practice so that this actor could credibly pull off the bit. So because the script had Ed playing all these different songs with only a couple weeks notice, he asked Phil Shea to rent a sitar. He went to Ed. He said, I'll get you a tutor.
所以大家可能知道埃德会弹吉他。他会弹班卓琴。兰迪告诉我，在他职业生涯的早期，他曾制作过另一档节目，当时他们需要一个演员在西塔尔琴上一首歌。这个演员也是个吉他手，但有人告诉他西塔尔琴是一门非常难演奏的乐器。它非常难正确调音。而且在那个节目的那个情境下，他不得不请一个家教，并留出大约四周的练习时间，才能让这个演员可信地完成这个桥段。所以因为剧本要求埃德只用提前几周通知就弹奏所有这些不同的歌，他要求菲尔·谢伊去租一把西塔尔琴。他去找了埃德。他说，我给你找个家教。
Yeah. But Ed said, I'll figure it out. And Randy was like, okay. Ed's like, I play the banjo. I'm going to flex a little bit. A little bit. I got this. And Ed totally, totally did it. He just picked it up and played it. Yes.
对。但埃德说，我自己琢磨。兰迪当时就想，好吧。埃德就像是在说，我会弹班卓琴。我要小秀一下。就一点点。这事我拿得下。结果埃德真的、真的做到了。他拿起来就弹了。是的。
I have a little catch where Ed slipped up. What? So you guys listening, my family and my close friends, they call me Ange. It's my nickname and my family. And it's like what my husband calls me and my mom, you know, everyone calls me Ange. Well, Ed called me Ange, right? In real life. Yeah. He never called me Angela. And right when he starts playing the sitar at four minutes, twenty-one seconds, tell me what you hear.
我有一个小细节捕捉到了埃德说漏嘴。什么？所以大家听好了，我的家人和我的密友都叫我“安吉（Ange）”。这是我在家里的昵称。就像我丈夫叫我的那样，还有我妈妈，你知道的，每个人都叫我安吉。好吧，埃德叫我安吉了，对吧？在现实生活中。他从不叫我安吉拉。就在他开始弹西塔尔琴的四分钟二十一秒时，告诉我你听到了什么。
Hey, Ange, check it out. There's a place in France where the naked lady is dance. Oh, wow. He called me Ange, not Angela. And Angela Martin would have never let Andy call her Ange. Anyone call her Ange. No. She's using the formal version of her name only.
嘿，安吉，你看。法国有个地方，那里的裸女在跳舞。哦，天哪。他叫我安吉，而不是安吉拉。而安吉拉·马丁绝不会让安迪叫她安吉。让任何人叫她安吉。绝不。她只用她名字的正式版本。
Only. For sure. Only Dwight can call her Monkey. Everyone else calls her Angela. In that moment, to me, Ed just sort of slipped and just was like, Hey, Ange. He was probably like concentrating on his playing. Yeah. Right? He was in musician mode.
只用。肯定的。只有德怀特可以叫她“小猴子”。其他人一律叫她安吉拉。那一刻，对我来说，埃德只是有点说漏嘴了，然后就说，嘿，安吉。他大概是在专心弹琴吧。对吧？他进入了音乐人模式。
Yeah. That just warmed my heart when I heard it. I just had to share. Well, next up is quite a scene. Meredith is dancing up a storm in the conference room and she sets her hair on fire. Yes. Dwight has to rush in and put it out with a fire extinguisher. Oh lady, talk about mail. People need to know how did they pull off this stunt where her hair catches on fire? Was it Kate? Was it a stunt double? We have a lot to share with you because this is one of the biggest stunts I think we ever
对。我听到的时候心里暖洋洋的。我只是不得不分享一下。好吧，接下来是一场重头戏。梅瑞狄斯在会议室里疯狂热舞，然后把自己的头发给点着了。是的。德怀特不得不冲进去用灭火器把它扑灭。哦，天哪，说到邮件。大家都很想知道，她头发着火这个特技是怎么做出来的？是凯特本人吗？还是替身？我们有很多东西要和大家分享，因为这绝对算得上是我们拍过的最大特技之一
did in the bullpen. For sure. For sure. A person was on fire. Yeah. All right. Well, I got some of the info from Randy. And I got info from Kate. So let's break it down. First of all, we did use a stunt double for Kate. Her name was Marie Fink.
在办公区里。肯定的。肯定的。有人着火了。好了。我从兰迪那里得到了一些信息。我从凯特那里也得到了信息。所以我们来剖析一下。首先，我们确实为凯特用了特技替身。她的名字叫玛丽·芬克。
Our stunt coordinator that day was Scott Aliva and he had to like do a bunch of prep for this. He had to like send a whole plan into NBC Universal Safety Department explaining how exactly we would do this safely. We had safety officers on set. We had a special effects crew on set and we had the LA Fire Department on set. Kate said there were so many people from the fire department there that they like took up a whole wall. I believe it.
我们当天的特技指导是斯科特·阿里瓦，他为此做了大量的准备工作。他必须向NBC环球安全部门提交一份完整的计划，详细解释我们将如何安全地完成这个动作。我们在片场配备了安全员。我们在片场有特效团队，还在片场安排了洛杉矶消防局。凯特说，现场消防局的人多得像一面墙一样。我信。
Yeah. What a crazy day of work for them. Now Paul Feig specifically staged this scene so that Meredith was dancing alone in the conference room and this was done to make it safer. Yes. And they dressed the stunt double Marie in this full fireproof body suit. It's called like a Nomex and she wore like a head stocking that was flame proof. And then she put on Kate's wardrobe.
对。对他们来说这是多么疯狂的一天工作啊。现在保罗·费格特意这样安排这场戏，让梅瑞狄斯一个人在会议室里跳舞，这样做是为了更安全。是的。他们给特技替身玛丽穿上了这身全防火连体衣。它被称为诺梅克斯（Nomex）材质，她还戴了一个防火的头套。然后她穿上了凯特的戏服。
I guess these Nomex suits are what race car drivers wear when they're racing, you know, in case their cars burst into flames. Yeah. Then Kim Ferry had to create a bunch of wigs. Yes. And Kate shared about these wigs, you guys. Kate said, Angie, they were natural hair and then they actually burned the wigs with fire. And she said, I had to wear the stinkiest wig the whole rest of the week because you know when you burn hair, you know the smell.
我猜这些诺梅克斯连体衣就是赛车手在比赛时穿的那种，你知道的，以防他们的车突然起火。对。然后金·费里不得不制作了一堆假发。是的。凯特跟我们分享了关于这些假发的事，伙计们。凯特说，安吉，那是真发，然后他们真的用火烧了这些假发。她说，我一整周剩下的时间都得戴着这顶臭气熏天的假发，因为你知道当你烧头发时，你知道那个味道。
Oh, I know it well. I mean, once you've smelled that, it's like burned into your brain. Yes. So Kate had to wear the stinky wig the rest of the week. Well, I guess to pull off this stunt, they put this flammable gel all over Marie's body and her hair. And then she used one of the actual real candles in the conference room to set her hair on fire. I guess they did have a stunt double dressed as Dwight. His name was Sean Crowder. But in the end, it was actually rain. Rain ran in and put out the stunt double with an actual fire extinguisher.
哦，我太清楚了。我的意思是，一旦你闻过那个味道，它就像是被烙印在你的大脑里一样。是的。所以凯特这一周剩下的时间都得戴着那顶臭假发。好吧，我猜为了完成这个特技，他们在玛丽的全身和头发上涂满了这种易燃凝胶。然后她用会议室里的一支真蜡烛点燃了自己的头发。我猜他们确实有一个打扮成德怀特的特技替身。他的名字叫肖恩·克劳德。但最后，其实是雷恩。雷恩跑过来，用真正的灭火器扑灭了特技替身身上的火。
I know. No pressure rain, right? But Kate said he did it. And then Kate said for continuity, they had to take Marie out. And Kate stepped back in with the burnt wig, right? Yeah, the smelly burnt wig. The smelly burnt wig kind of assumed the same position Marie was in. And then rain had to spray Kate with the real fire extinguisher. So Kate got hosed as well. Justin told me that we did it all in one take. I'm so glad for everyone's sake. Yeah.
我懂。雷恩当时压力山大，对吧？但凯特说他做到了。然后凯特说为了连戏，他们必须把玛丽带走。凯特戴着烧焦的假发重新上场了，对吧？对，那顶臭烘烘的烧焦假发。那顶臭烘烘的烧焦假发基本上回到了玛丽刚才摆的那个姿势。然后雷恩不得不拿真的灭火器喷凯特。所以凯特也遭殃了。贾斯汀告诉我，我们一条就过了。我真为大家好。对。
I'm so glad. Also, look at Kate's dancing. This is like lunging forward and back and forward and back. And I'm like, Kate, were you sore? My gosh. That's like a physical day. Randy told me that Kate and Marie got together and planned out the dance moves. So that Marie could look exactly like Kate and her movements. Yes. Which is amazing to me because it looks like completely spontaneous dancing, but they really planned it so that it would coordinate. So they were doing the same thing.
我太高兴了。另外，看看凯特的舞姿。这就像是前后弓步，前后弓步。我当时就想，凯特，你肌肉酸痛吗？天哪。这真是一场体力消耗巨大的一天。兰迪告诉我，凯特和玛丽聚在一起策划了这些舞蹈动作。这样玛丽的动作就能看起来和凯特一模一样。是的。这让我觉得太神奇了，因为它看起来完全是即兴舞蹈，但他们确实精心策划过，以便能够协调一致。所以他们跳的是同一支舞。
Yes. And if you watch the episode, it's very rare that only one person is in the conference room at a party. But that was for everyone's safety, like you said. Yeah. So Kate said it was kind of odd to be in there alone for all those takes, like a fishbowl. But I really related because there's a whole scene coming up where you guys are all together on the floor and I'm in the kitchen. I know. For the whole episode.
是的。如果你看了这一集，你会发现派对上会议室里只有一个人是非常罕见的。但就像你说的，那是为了每个人的安全。是的。所以凯特说一个人待在里面拍完所有镜头感觉有点奇怪，就像在一个鱼缸里。但我真的很有共鸣，因为接下来有一场戏，你们所有人都坐在办公区的地板上，而我在厨房里。我懂。整整一集。
I know. Lady, I think we should take a little break and then we'll come back and make you go to the kitchen. Make me go to the kitchen and Michael is going to share with us about a responsibility. Oh, I can't wait. It's a deleted scene. I can't wait to share. So we are back. Oscar, you have a little bit of granola on your boob.
我懂。我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后回来让你去厨房。让我去厨房，而迈克尔将跟我们分享一个“责任”。哦，我等不及了。这是一段被删减的片段。我迫不及待想分享了。我们回来了。奥斯卡，你的胸口上有一点格兰诺拉麦片。
Oh, thanks for telling me. We ate a granola bar during the break. You're eating it off your shirt. What else would I do? If I pick it off, I have to what, throw it on the floor? No, put it in the trash. Well, you would still hungry. You'd fit in very well with my boys. Listen, we're friends here.
哦，谢谢你告诉我。我们在休息时吃了一根格兰诺拉麦片棒。你直接从衬衫上把它吃下去了。不然我还能怎么做？如果我把它捡起来，我难道要把它扔到地上吗？不，把它扔进垃圾桶。好吧，你还是会觉得饿。你跟我儿子们绝对能玩到一块去。听着，我们都是朋友。
I've seen them eat things off their clothing too. Oh my God. Listen, every once in a while, you're going to lick a piece of granola bar off your shirt. You know what else I'm going to do sometimes? Sometimes the salad dressing is so good. I lick the plate. Okay, I'm here for licking the plate, but you just ate a piece of granola off your t-shirt. You lifted your shirt up towards you so you could eat that tiny piece of granola. Because I'm a classy lady.
我也见过他们从衣服上捡东西吃。哦，天哪。听着，偶尔你会把衬衫上的一块格兰诺拉麦片舔掉。你知道我有时还会做什么吗？有时候沙拉酱太好吃了。我会舔盘子。好吧，舔盘子我能理解，但你刚刚从T恤上吃了一块格兰诺拉麦片。你把衬衫向上拉向自己，好把那小块格兰诺拉麦片吃掉。因为我是个有品位的女士。
You are classy. And you know what? You do not waste. And that I respect. Thank you. Okay. As I was saying, Oscar, Jim, Michael and Stanley try to set a date for something. We don't know what they're talking about. They're trying to agree on a time to do something. Nothing's working. We do learn that Michael goes to the dentist every month. Well, because of his soft teeth.
你确实很有品位。你知道吗？你从不浪费。这一点我很尊重。谢谢。好吧。正如我所说，奥斯卡、吉姆、迈克尔和斯坦利试图为某事定一个日期。我们不知道他们在谈论什么。他们正试图就做某件事的时间达成一致。什么都不行。我们确实了解到迈克尔每个月都去看牙医。好吧，因为他的牙齿很脆弱。
Every month. We establish that in dinner party. I feel like he talks their ear off. I feel like there's like a dental hygienist that he just talks their ear off. What do you do for soft teeth? You know what? I'm going to ask Mike Dennis the next time I'm there. He's a fan of the show. He's also a bread maker. And he gave me his sourdough discard and it is fantastic sourdough discard. Wow.
每个月。我们在“晚宴派对”里就确立了这一点。我觉得他把牙医的耳朵都快磨出茧了。我觉得有一个牙医助理，他就是一直在人家耳边喋喋不休。牙齿脆弱该怎么办？你知道吗？下次我去的时候我要问问迈克·丹尼斯牙医。他是本剧的粉丝。他还会做面包，他给了我他的酸面团面头，那酸面团面头太棒了。哇。
Great dentist. Okay. Great baker. I'm going to ask him about soft teeth. Stay tuned. Baker and a dentist. Listen, they also can't do it on Groundhog Day because Michael, he celebrates privately. Some fans asked Justin in an interview once, what is it that Michael's doing? And he said, I imagine he just watches Groundhog Day all day, the movie. He watches the movie.
好牙医。好吧。好面包师。我要去问问他关于牙齿脆弱的事。敬请期待。既是面包师又是牙医。听着，他们也不能在土拨鼠日那天办，因为迈克尔，他要私下庆祝。有粉丝曾在一次采访中问贾斯汀，迈克尔到底在干什么？他说，我猜他一整天都在看《土拨鼠日》这部电影。他在看电影。
And I also think he watches to see if punks a Tony. Is it punks a Tony? Phil? Yeah. I think he watches to see if Phil sees the shadow. I think he watches the whole broadcast. It's a big event. Maybe he goes. He's busy. That's what we know. Yeah.
而且我也觉得他在看菲尔（Punxsutawney Phil）有没有出来。是庞克斯托尼·菲尔吗？对。我觉得他在看菲尔有没有看到自己的影子。我觉得他看了整个转播。这是一件大事。也许他会去。他很忙。这就是我们所知道的。对。
In the end, they decide today is the day and what they're planning is an intervention. Christmas Eve, office party, intervention. Listen, if I had to explain what an intervention is, it's like a surprise party for people who have addictions. And what you do is you make them feel badly about themselves so they stop. Michael Scott. Right there, guys. Her Michael Scott.
最后，他们决定今天就是日子，他们正在计划的是一场干预。平安夜，办公室派对，干预。听着，如果我要解释什么是干预，它就像是为有瘾的人举办的一个惊喜派对。而你要做的是让他们对自己感到糟糕，这样他们就会停下来。迈克尔·斯科特。就是这样，伙计们。这就是迈克尔·斯科特。
That was the talking head that made it into the show. Here is an alt that got deleted and it cracked me up. We're going to call this responsibility, guys. It takes a lot of courage to admit you are right. And talking about my strengths has always been one of my strengths. And I am right. Meredith needs help. She needs help like an alcoholic needs a drink. And she's about to get a big shot of Michael Scott. Straight up on the rocks with ice. No chaser. I call it a responsibility. Shaken with lemon twist. Okay. Okay. We've played a lot of talking heads that didn't make it. A lot of scenes that didn't make it in the show. This is the biggest tragedy.
那是剪进正片里的单人访谈。这里有一个被删减的备选，把我逗得前仰后合。我们把这个称为“责任”，伙计们。承认自己是对的需要很大的勇气。而谈论我的优点一直是我的优点之一。我是对的。梅瑞狄斯需要帮助。她需要帮助的程度，就像酒鬼需要一杯酒一样。而她即将迎来迈克尔·斯科特的猛烈一击。纯饮，加冰。不加任何佐饮。我管这叫责任。摇匀，加一片柠檬。好吧。好吧。我们播放了很多未被采用的单人访谈。很多没有剪进正片里的戏份。这才是最大的悲剧。
A responsibility. Everything about that was gold. I could listen to it five times. I know. I was like, I have to play it. This is gold. That was like on the level of Dwight's whole speech about stealing the ball from Tiffany's and going to all the countries and all that. Oh my God. It was so good. I'm going to get a big shot of Michael Scott. Shaken, not stirred. Responsibility. That's incredible. Well, we're all going to circle up on the floor now. Not Angela, though. Phyllis has other plans for you. It involves a hair net. Lots of fanning. Got a fan of some pitas. Got a toaster on both sides. Got a fan napkins.
一个责任。关于那个的一切都是黄金。我可以听五遍。我知道。我当时就想，我非播不可。这太棒了。那简直达到了德怀特关于从蒂凡尼偷走球并去过所有国家的整段演讲的水平。哦，天哪。太棒了。我要来上一大剂迈克尔·斯科特。摇匀，不要搅拌。责任。这太不可思议了。好了，现在我们要围坐在地板上了。不过安吉拉除外。菲莉丝为你准备了别的安排。这涉及一个发网。不停地扇扇子。拿个扇子扇皮塔饼。两边都用烤面包机烤。拿扇子当餐巾纸。
And off to the kitchen I go. Meanwhile, the rest of us sit on the floor and engage in a real uncomfortable intervention of Meredith. I don't know how you guys got through the scene without laughing. I remember two things happening during this week. One, I was bummed because I was in the kitchen by myself. Yep. And I had to enter in during the scene. So it's not like I had to be there. Do you remember this? Because Justin reminded me of this and I had forgotten it, which was that Paul Feig insisted on shooting the entire intervention scene from top to bottom without cutting and every take was about eight minutes long.
然后我就去厨房了。与此同时，我们其他人坐在地板上，对梅瑞狄斯进行了一场极其尴尬的干预。我不知道你们是怎么忍住不笑拍完这场戏的。我记得这周发生了两件事。第一，我很沮丧，因为我一个人待在厨房里。是的。而且我必须在戏进行中途入场。所以不像我必须全程都在场。你还记得这个吗？因为贾斯汀提醒了我这件事，而我都快忘光了，那就是保罗·费格坚持从头到尾一镜到底地拍摄整场干预戏，中间不喊停，每一个镜头大约都有八分钟长。
Yes. So I would be in the kitchen like with a magazine. I actually, on the DVD commentary, I said I brought a magazine back there eventually because I was back there so long and then they would cue me and then I would walk in, then I'd have to go back. So crazy. So crazy. I remember my legs fell asleep. It's very hard to sit on the floor in a pencil skirt and pantyhose. Well, you had to do an odd cross. You had to do that one foot under the other and at nine minutes, 46 seconds, there's a real good Pam pantyhose catch.
是的。所以我就会拿着一本杂志待在厨房里。实际上，在DVD评论音轨里我说过，因为我在后面待了太久，后来我甚至带了一本杂志去后面，然后他们会给我cue点，接着我走进去，然后我又得回去。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。我记得我的腿都麻了。穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜坐在地板上是非常难受的。好吧，你得摆出一个奇怪的交叉姿势。你必须把一只脚压在另一只脚下面，在九分钟四十六秒的时候，有一个非常精彩的帕姆连裤袜穿帮镜头。
Oh, yeah. I can see your pantyhose. I don't doubt it. You have pantyhose toes. I remember trying to figure out because, you know, once you pick the way you're sitting, you have to sit like that. You can't shift and move or change your position. Because it has to match, you guys. So however you sit, that's it. So Mindy laying on her stomach like that.
哦，对。我能看到你的连裤袜。我毫不怀疑。你有连裤袜脚趾。我记得我当时在想，因为，你知道的，一旦你选定了坐姿，你就得一直这么坐着。你不能挪动、调整或者改变你的姿势。因为必须连戏，伙计们。所以你以什么姿势坐，那就是什么姿势。比如明迪那样趴在肚子上。
Oh, I was so jealous. Which I took a picture of. I was jealous at first, but then you know her back started to ache. It had to because that's like doing a, what is that, the cow? No, it's not a cow. It's the snake. It's a yoga thing. Oh, yeah. What's that yoga pose called? Where you... We are. Cobra. Cobra.
哦，我当时嫉妒死了。我还拍了张照片呢。一开始我很嫉妒，但后来你知道她的背开始酸痛了。那是肯定的，因为那就像是在做个，那叫什么来着，猫式？不，不是猫式。是蛇式。那是瑜伽动作。哦，对。那个瑜伽体式叫什么来着？当你在……我们是。眼镜蛇式。眼镜蛇式。
Cobra. I knew it. I don't know why that was so exciting, but I just recalling any information at my age just gets me real amped up. So she had to do a mini cobra all day. You had to sit with the one foot under your butt, one foot extended. Yep. I know. And I do remember that we went around and, you know, I was mostly reactions. I don't think I had any lines in this scene. It was very hard not to laugh. It was very
眼镜蛇式。我猜对了。我不知道为什么这让我这么兴奋，但以我这个年纪，只要能回忆起任何信息都会让我感到非常亢奋。所以她一整天都得做一个迷你眼镜蛇式。你必须一只脚塞在屁股底下坐着，另一只脚伸直。对。我知道。我确实记得我们转了一圈，而且，你知道的，我基本上都是做反应。我觉得在这场戏里我没有任何台词。要忍住不笑真的很难。非常
hard not to laugh when Creed says that he can get a fire permit in a couple hours. It was pretty amazing. We talked on the DVD commentary about Creed's outfit and what he's wearing in this scene. He actually wore something similar to an award show. Do you remember? He wore the long white... I don't remember this. This is very much sort of his outfit is something Creed would actually wear. And he looks fantastic. There is a delicious Andy talking head. I feel like we all knew this guy in college, the guy that would chug a fifth of Soco.
当克里德说他能在几个小时内弄到消防许可证时，要忍住不笑真的很难。这太惊艳了。我们在DVD评论音轨里讨论过克里德的穿着，以及他在这一场戏里穿的衣服。他其实在某个颁奖典礼上穿过类似的衣服。你还记得吗？他穿了那件长长的白色……我不记得这个了。这非常符合克里德平时会穿的风格。而且他看起来帅呆了。这里有一段安迪极其精彩的单人访谈。我觉得我们在大学里都认识这种家伙，就是那种会一口气吹干一整瓶南方舒适力娇酒（Soco）的家伙。
Uh-huh. Boot, rally. How many nicknames does he have, by the way? He's puke. He's ace, Andy's buzz. Did he get straight A's or straight B's? We're not sure. He got straight B's. Yeah, but he aced everything. Yeah. Well, surprise, surprise, this intervention does not result in Meredith deciding to go to rehab.
嗯哼。Boot、Rally。顺便问一下，他有多少个绰号？他是呕吐狂（puke）。他是王牌（ace），安迪是巴兹（buzz）。他拿的全是A还是全的B？我们不确定。他拿的全是B。对，但他每门都考得顶呱呱。对。好吧，意料之中，这次干预并没有让梅丽迪丝决定去戒酒。
Michael's clearly not qualified to do this. And Toby's going to call it. He's like, you know what? We're going to stop this. I do have to point out one of my favorite moments when Kevin offers his way that her drinking affected him. He got to go to the movies. By the way, thank you, he says. Yeah. Michael's like, you're not getting it. But you're right. Michael is not trained to do
迈克尔显然不适合做这事。而托比要叫停了。他就像是，你知道吗？我们要阻止这个。我必须指出我最喜欢的时刻之一，当凯文说出她酗酒对他的影响。他得以去看电影。顺便说一句，谢谢你，他说。对。迈克尔的反应是，你没明白。但你说得对。迈克尔没有受过做
this. You know, a trained interventionist. This is a job in real life. People trained for this. Yeah. Kate had a whole speech that was in the script as Meredith, where she just addresses the group and she's like, listen, I'm bored. You're boring. She said to Michael and he goes, Hey, and she was like, you know what? I drink because I'm bored. Try to be more interesting. Oh my God.
这个的培训。你知道，一个受过培训的干预员。现实生活中这是个职业。人们为此接受过培训。对。凯特作为梅丽迪丝，剧本里有一大段台词，她只是对大家说，听着，我很无聊。你们很无聊。她对迈克尔说，然后迈克尔说，嘿，而她说，你知道吗？我喝酒是因为我无聊。试着变得有趣点。天哪。
And she's like, who else is bored here? And like everyone raises their hand. She like hijacks the meeting from Michael, right? And then she's like, we all do things to cope. So I drink when I'm bored. And then she goes around the room. She goes, you all have coping mechanisms. You eat, you eat, you eat, you shop, you confuse Dwight. And then she's like, Who confuses Dwight? Me. No, me.
然后她说，这里还有谁无聊？然后所有人举手。她直接从迈克尔手里接管了会议，对吧？然后她说，我们都会用各种方式应对。所以我无聊时就喝酒。接着她环顾四周。她说，你们都有应对机制。你吃，你吃，你吃，你购物，你把德怀特搞糊涂。然后她说，谁把德怀特搞糊涂？我。不对，我。
Oh, okay. And then she like points at Stanley and she's like, you eat. And then Stanley has a talking head where he's like, I do eat when I'm bored. But I also drink and I drink a lot more than Meredith. I just don't do it at work and I keep my clothes on. Oh my goodness. Yes, this scene was way bigger. Wow. Michael is going to take Meredith into his office where they're going to talk for 45
哦，好吧。然后她指着斯坦利说，你吃。接着斯坦利有一个单采镜头，他说，我无聊时确实会吃。但我也喝酒，而且我喝得比梅丽迪丝多得多。我只是不在工作时喝，而且我还穿着衣服。噢天哪。是的，这个场面本来要大得多。哇。迈克尔要把梅丽迪丝带进他的办公室，他们要在那里谈45
minutes. 45 minutes. And in the meantime, Angela is going to plead with Phyllis. Please can I stop cutting the pita? Do I really have to wear the hair net? Have mercy. It's the season of mercy. Phyllis is no. No. I have a thing I want to point out at 13 minutes, 35 seconds. Phyllis is telling Stanley about the Moroccan food they're eating and Angela's eating this cookie. She spits it out.
分钟。45分钟。与此同时，安吉拉恳求菲利斯。求求你，我能不能别再切皮塔饼了？我真的必须戴发网吗？行行好吧。这是慈悲的季节。菲利斯说不行。不行。我有一件事想在13分35秒时指出。菲利斯在向斯坦利讲他们正在吃的摩洛哥食物，而安吉拉在吃这个曲奇饼干。她把它吐了出来了。
Yeah. We did a lot of takes of this. I'm not sure why. Okay. But the cookie started to turn on me because I took a big bite. Okay. Mistake. Okay. Take a small bite, guys.
对。我们拍了好几次。我不确定为什么。好吧。但那块饼干开始让我难受了，因为我咬了一大口。好吧。失误。好吧，咬小口一点，伙计们。
Always. Always. Because by the eighth take, the thought of that cookie makes you want to barf. Right. It doesn't matter what it is. It doesn't matter if it's your favorite dessert. And it started to turn on me. And so I took some peanuts and I stuck them in my hand. And when they would cut to me eating, I would like just put a bunch of the peanuts in my mouth and hold the cookie. I was trying to do a fakey eat. Mmm.
一直都要。因为到了第八条，一想到那块饼干就让你想吐。对吧。不管它是什么。不管它是不是你最喜欢的甜点。它开始让我难受了。所以我拿了一些花生塞在手里。当镜头切到我吃的时候，我就会把一把花生放进嘴里，手里拿着饼干。我试图假装在吃。嗯。
Fakey eat. Fakey eat. And then I would spit out peanuts instead of the cookie. Okay. So what we see on camera, that is chewed up peanuts? We don't know. We don't know which take they used. We don't know which take they used. Was it early?
假装吃。假装吃。然后我会吐出花生而不是饼干。好吧。所以我们在镜头里看到的，那是嚼烂的花生？我们不知道。我们不知道他们用了哪一条。我们不知道他们用了哪一条。是早期的？
Was it late? I don't know. These are the things you try to do at work. How do I not eat that cookie? Well, when Michael leaves his office with Meredith, they're going somewhere. He says, I'll meet you in the parking lot. And then he asks Toby for the number of that rehabilitation center. And everyone's like, wow, he did it. And then, you know, he finishes writing the number down and he throws the pen at Toby's head.
还是后期的？我不知道。这些是你在工作中试图做的事。我怎么才能不吃那块饼干？好吧，当迈克尔带着梅丽迪丝离开办公室时，他们要去某个地方。他说，我在停车场等你。然后他向托比要那个康复中心的电话号码。每个人都觉得，哇，他做到了。然后，你知道，他写完号码，把笔朝托比的头上扔去。
And hits him in the forehead. We got a fan question about that. Well, we have stories about it too. Kelsey B would like to know, was the pen throwing scripted or improvised? It was scripted. And Justin said that Steve had a special rubber pen. And I remember it because it was in the pen cup on Pam's desk. There were real pens and then one fakie pen. And I was sitting there and I kept like positioning the pen so that Steve could pick up the fakie pen. This would have been another thing Phil Shea would have had to have gotten for the episode.
正中他的额头。我们收到了一个关于这的粉丝提问。好吧，我们也有相关的故事。凯尔西·B想知道，扔笔是剧本里写好的还是即兴发挥的？是剧本写好的。贾斯汀说史蒂夫有一支特殊的橡胶笔。我还记得，因为它就在潘姆桌上的笔筒里。有真正的笔，然后还有一支假笔。我坐在那儿，一直摆弄着那支笔，好让史蒂夫能拿起那支假笔。这本来应该是菲尔·谢伊得为这一集准备的另一件道具。
Fakie rubber pen so that he could throw it at Toby's head. They inserted that little thump sound later. We did about four or five takes of it, I guess. You guys, if you rewatch this, you will notice behind Michael, there are no people. We're all standing way off to the right. You want to know why? Because we couldn't stop laughing. So when they would cut to Michael, after throwing it, we'd be behind him giggling. So they pushed us all to the right and they had to get our reaction take like a whole beat later when we had gotten our composure. Paul also couldn't stop laughing.
假的橡胶笔，这样他就可以把它扔向托比的头。他们后来加入了那个小小的闷响。我想我们大概拍了四五条。大家伙儿，如果你重看这一集，你会发现迈克尔身后没有人。我们都远远地站在最右边。你想知道为什么吗？因为我们笑得停不下来。所以当镜头切到迈克尔，在他扔完之后，我们就在他身后咯咯笑。所以他们把我们都推到了右边，不得不等我们平静下来后的整整一拍才拍我们的反应镜头。保罗也笑得停不下来。
I know. Every time that little rubber pen thumped him in the forehead, he would break. I know. And there is such a fun blooper where Paul decided to prank Steve during the scene. We have to listen to it. You know, could you write down the name of that rehabilitation clinic you mentioned? What did he do? Instead of writing down a fake phone number, he wrote f*** you. So Steve in the scene glances down and it says f*** you and he started laughing and he couldn't even throw the pen because he was laughing too hard.
我知道。每次那支小橡胶笔闷声砸在他额头上，他就会笑场。我知道。有一个超级有趣的失误，保罗决定在拍摄这场戏时对史蒂夫恶作剧。我们必须听听这个。你知道，你能写下你提到的那家康复诊所的名字吗？他做了什么？他没有写一个假的电话号码，而是写了“去你的”。所以史蒂夫在戏里低头一看，上面写着“去你的”，他开始大笑，他甚至都扔不出去了，因为他笑得太厉害了。
That is so funny. Well, have you know, fake pen lived in the pen cup for weeks after we shot the scene and people were always coming over trying to grab a pen to use and they would get fake rubber pen. And I never got rid of it because it just was funny to me. Yeah. It was funny to me that people would grab a fake pen. So now Meredith and Michael are in the car. This is going to start such a fantastic sequence between Meredith and Michael. Both Steve and Kate just knock it out of the park. They're driving. Meredith thinks they're going to a bar. She's listing off all these bars and
太搞笑了。好吧，你知道吗，假笔在拍完这场戏后的几周里一直待在笔筒里，人们总是走过来抓一支笔用，然后就会拿到那支假的橡胶笔。我从来没有把它扔掉，因为我觉得这太好玩了。对。我觉得人们会抓起一支假笔这事很有趣。现在梅丽迪丝和迈克尔在车里。这开启了梅丽迪丝和迈克尔之间一段精彩绝伦的戏。史蒂夫和凯特简直发挥得淋漓尽致。他们在开车。梅丽迪丝以为他们要去酒吧。她列举了所有这些酒吧，然后
Kate Flannery said in real life she kept trying to slip her family's bar in there. Because you know, her family owned a bar in Philadelphia called Flannery's. Yep. But it didn't make it in. But all the other bars she says are local Scranton bars. They're real places. Yeah. Well, that was part of the reasons why Flannery's wouldn't have checked out, right? But she also wanted you guys to know that Steve did his own driving. They're not being pulled.
凯特·弗兰纳里在现实中说，她一直试图把她家族的酒吧塞进去。因为你知道，她的家族在费城开了一家酒吧，叫弗兰纳里的酒吧。是的。但没能剪进去。但她说的所有其他酒吧都是斯克兰顿当地的酒吧。都是真实的地方。对。好吧，这也是弗兰纳里酒吧行不通的原因之一吧？但她也想让你们知道，史蒂夫是自己开的车。车子不是被拖着走的。
Yeah. You can kind of tell. Yeah. He's driving and doing all the dialogue because there were those little lipstick cameras. And then they had, I think, a truck in front of them with a camera rigged on the back to get them through the windshield. Mm-hmm. When they finally arrive at their destination, it is revealed that they are at Sunrise Rehab. Meredith gets super pissed. So pissed. So pissed. Now, Kate told me they had stunt people there for her and Steve.
对。你其实能看得出来。对。他一边开车一边说所有的台词，因为车里装了那些微型唇膏摄像机。然后他们好像在前面安排了一辆卡车，卡车后面架着摄像机，以便从挡风玻璃拍到他们。嗯哼。当他们终于到达目的地时，发现他们来到了日出康复中心。梅丽迪丝超级生气。气炸了。气炸了。凯特告诉我，现场有替身演员为她和史蒂夫准备着。
Should it get too physical that they could have this choreographed thing with the stunt people? Mm-hmm. And her and Steve were like, no, we're going to go for it. Kate was like, Steve, let's do it. And they did not use the stunt people. Everything you see is actually Kate and Steve just freaking going for it. I think I noticed one moment we cut out of it really quickly. When Meredith throws the trash can down and it looks like Michael trips and falls, I feel like I see Kate start to
以防动作太大，他们可以和替身演员一起排练这些动作戏？嗯哼。而她和史蒂夫说，不，我们要亲自上阵。凯特说，史蒂夫，我们来吧。他们没有用替身演员。你看到的全部内容其实都是凯特和史蒂夫真刀真枪拼出来的。我想我注意到一个我们很快剪掉的镜头。当梅丽迪丝把垃圾桶扔下，看起来像迈克尔绊倒摔倒时，我觉得我看到凯特开始
check on Steve. Oh, yeah? Like maybe like, oh, are you okay? Like just the littlest moment and we cut out of it. And then they, you know, they have a bigger chase around the parking lot. Well, Kate said that's fakey trash. Fakey trash. That was fakey trash. So whatever Steve fell on wasn't real trash. So Phil Shea also had to make fakey trash.
查看史蒂夫的情况。哦，是吗？就像，哦，你没事吧？就像是一个极小的瞬间，然后我们剪掉了。接着他们，你知道的，在停车场有一场更大规模的追逐。好吧，凯特说那是假垃圾。假垃圾。那是假垃圾。所以史蒂夫摔在上面的东西不是真的垃圾。所以菲尔·谢伊还得制作假垃圾。
Yes. Oh my gosh, this man's week was insane. Yes. This scene was scripted at the top where she doesn't want to get out of the car, but they immediately then just went off. Yeah. You know, because Paul Feig just wanted them to really go for it, not worry about the lines. And that whole sequence where Meredith is saying, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
是的。哦天哪，这家伙这一周太疯狂了。是的。这场戏开头剧本写的是她不想下车，但他们随后立刻就开始自由发挥了。对。你知道的，因为保罗·费格只是想让他们放开去演，不用担心台词。梅丽迪丝说“等一下，等一下，等一下”的整段戏。
I love that. That's not in the script. I loved it. It was so real. I thought Kate did such a great job. Well, this whole thing ends with Michael dragging Meredith into the rehab center. And we should tell you the intake nurse was played by our very own first assistant director, Kelly Cantley.
我太喜欢了。那不在剧本里。我太喜欢了。太真实了。我觉得凯特演得太棒了。好吧，这一切以迈克尔把梅丽迪丝拖进康复中心而告终。我们应该告诉你们，接诊护士是由我们自己的第一副导演凯莉·坎特利扮演的。
Yes. She also helps escort them out. Yeah. At the end, when Michael discovers that you can't force people to go to rehab. Yep. And now awkward car ride back. But you know what Michael's going to do? Michael's had a realization. He realizes that, you know, in order to get help, a person has to hit their rock bottom. So he's going to make it his mission to help Meredith reach her rock bottom.
是的。她还帮忙把他们护送出去。对。最后，当迈克尔发现你无法强迫别人去戒酒时。没错。现在是尴尬的车程返程。但你知道迈克尔要干什么吗？迈克尔顿悟了。他意识到，你知道的，为了寻求帮助，一个人必须触底反弹。所以他的使命就是帮助梅丽迪丝触底反弹。
Oh, my gosh. And he thinks he can do it because he did it with Jan. Oh, my gosh. It's like an amazing line. They're still going to be quite a bit of drama back at the office. Oh, yes. We start with Toby. Oh, Toby, man.
噢，天哪。他觉得他能做到，因为他对简就是这么做的。噢，天哪。这真是一句绝妙的台词。办公室里依然会有相当多的戏剧冲突。哦，是的。我们从托比开始。哦，托比，老兄。
He thinks he's going to get to be the hero to his little girl. He is going to score one of the Princess Unicorn Dolls from Dwight for his daughter. But Dwight has sold them all out. He just sold his last one to Daryl. Yes. All right. I just unsolicited get this email from Jen Salata. About this scene?
他以为他能成为他宝贝女儿眼中的英雄。他要从德怀特那里为女儿抢到一个独角兽公主玩偶。但德怀特把它们全卖光了。他刚刚把最后一个卖给达里尔。是的。好吧。我突然无缘无故地收到了詹·萨拉塔的这封邮件。关于这场戏的？
About this scene and this episode. I guess the writers like Justin and Halstead and Aaron, they were all texting each other about this storyline. And somehow Jen got involved. This email pops in my inbox yesterday. She's like, Jenna, we've all been texting about the Princess Unicorn. Because you asked Justin about it? Yeah.
关于这场戏和这一集。我猜像贾斯汀、霍尔斯特德和亚伦这样的编剧们，他们都在互相发短信讨论这个故事情节。不知怎么的，詹也加入进来了。这封邮件昨天突然弹进我的收件箱。她说，珍娜，我们一直在发短信讨论独角兽公主。因为你问了贾斯汀这件事？对。
Okay. And she was like, I have a story and I asked Paul if I could share it. Okay. And I was like, oh, I'm so intrigued. She made an audio clip. Here it is. Oh, my gosh. There was a moment that happened behind the scenes of Moroccan Christmas where Paul and
好吧。她说，我有一个故事，我问过保罗我能不能分享。好吧，我想，哦，我太好奇了。她制作了一段音频剪辑。就是这个。噢，天哪。在《摩洛哥圣诞节》的幕后发生过这样一件事，当时保罗和
I were working on a script together. I'm not sure if it was the fifth season finale or what, but we were kind of under the gun. I remember when we were writing and he had to go down on set and shoot a scene as Toby. And then when he came back up, we needed to push forward on the script. And I remember that he was sitting on the couch and he was like, oh, I think I just screwed up that scene that I shot. And I was like, I probably didn't. I'm sure you didn't.
我在一块儿写剧本。我不确定那是第五季季终集还是什么，但我们当时有点时间紧迫。我记得我们正在写作时，他得下到片场去以托比的身份拍一场戏。然后当他回到楼上时，我们需要推进剧本。我记得他坐在沙发上，然后他说，哦，我觉得我刚才把拍的那场戏搞砸了。我说，我猜你没有。我确信你没有。
You're being hard on yourself. He's like, no, no, I really think I screwed it up. And he's kind of stuck on it and it was very typical of him. So I was like, tell me what happened. And he said, well, I was supposed to be upset and sad because I wanted this princess unicorn doll for my daughter. And Daryl wanted the doll for his daughter. And I needed to be really sad.
你对你自己太苛刻了。他说，不，不，我真的觉得我把它搞砸了。他有点纠结于这件事，这非常符合他的风格。所以我说，告诉我发生了什么。他说，嗯，我本该心烦意乱、伤心欲绝的，因为我想要这个独角兽公主玩偶送给女儿。而达里尔想要这个玩偶送给他的女儿。我需要表现得真的很伤心。
And so I thought of what Steve might do or what I thought Jenna might do, which is think of something sad that happened in real life to them and something that triggered these sad feelings and sad emotions and kind of be in that place and use it for the scene. And I said, well, it sounds smart. Like how to go. And he said, well, I didn't do that. And I asked him why. And he said, well, I thought about getting sad, but it didn't seem worth it.
所以我想象了史蒂夫会怎么做，或者我想象珍娜会怎么做，那就是去想一件现实中发生在他们身上的悲伤的事，去想一件能触动这些悲伤情绪和伤感感情的事，然后让自己进入那种状态，并把它用在戏里。我说，听起来挺聪明的。进展得怎么样？他说，嗯，我没有这么做。我问他为什么。他说，嗯，我想过要让自己伤心，但似乎不值得。
And I remember laughing at that, being like, I'm pretty sure you just made the decision not to act. I think that's what just happened in that moment. But I remember watching that scene later and thinking it was such a perfectly Toby choice. It was a great scene. And I feel like when you're Toby and you're going about the world and Michael's always making you feel put upon and all of this stuff, you can't constantly keep getting sad. So it ended up being a very, very wonderful choice that I think he made.
我记得当时听了哈哈大笑，心想，我敢肯定你刚刚做出了不演戏的决定。我想刚才那一刻发生的就是这个。但我记得后来看到那场戏时，觉得这是一个非常符合托比风格的选择。这是一场很棒的戏。我觉得当你是托比，你在世间穿行，而迈克尔总是让你觉得受委屈诸如此类的，你不可能一直保持悲伤。所以最后这成了一个非常非常棒的选择，我认为是他做出的选择。
But in the moment, I think he pretty much decided he wasn't going to act because he didn't want to be sad that day. And I'll never forget that. I loved it. Jen was so excited to tell me the story. She was like, I have to give him grief. And I guess they talked together and they were laughing about it. And Paul was like, yeah, you can share.
但在当时，我想他基本上决定了他不打算去演，因为他不想在那天感到悲伤。我永远不会忘记那个。我太喜欢了。詹非常兴奋地把这个故事讲给我听。她说，我得去逗逗他。我猜他们一起聊过，并且对此哈哈大笑。保罗说，行，你可以分享。
You can share that it's true. I don't want to be sad. I don't want to dig too deep and actually cry in this scene because then I'm going to be sad all day. I'm going to be thinking about my whatever precipitated it. I love that Jen just wanted to give Paul shit on our podcast. I know. She was just like, email hits my inbox.
你可以分享这是真的。我不想伤心。我不想挖得太深，在这场戏里真的哭出来，因为那样我一整天都会很难过。我会一直想着那些引发这一切的事情。我太喜欢詹只是想在我们的播客里损保罗这件事了。我知道。她就觉得，邮件弹进我的收件箱。
Oh, so funny. I agree though. When I watched the scene, like I didn't think anything of it. I was like, oh, that's perfect. Yeah. Oh, so funny. And I guess she would like give him shiitake about that for years to come. Gosh.
哦，太搞笑了。不过我同意。当我看到那场戏时，我什么都没想。我心想，哦，这太完美了。耶。哦，太搞笑了。我猜她在接下来的几年里都会拿这个来取笑他。天哪。
Speaking of sad. Did we talk about the saddest scene ever? Saddest scene ever. It all starts because Angela is done. She is done with Phyllis. Well, Phyllis tells her to go get the tree and bring it back. I know. Phyllis and I absolutely loved this episode.
说到伤心。我们聊过史上最伤心的场面吗？史上最伤心的场面。这一切的起因是安吉拉受够了。她受够了菲利斯。好吧，菲利斯让她去把树拿来并带回办公室。我知道。菲利斯和我绝对爱死这一集了。
We got to do so much together even more than you even see in the actual episode. I can't tell you how amazing it felt as Angela Martin to turn to her and say, shut up. It felt so good. And I was really proud of the scene. I thought Phyllis and I really had this perfect chemistry in this moment. And then she tells everyone and she shames Angela Martin in front of the whole bullpen. And when she did, I was so in the moment with her, I felt the heat of my skin. Like my face started to flush.
我们俩有那么多对手戏，甚至比你在正片里看到的还要多。我无法形容作为安吉拉·马丁转过身对她说“闭嘴”时感觉有多爽。感觉太棒了。我真的为这场戏感到骄傲。我觉得我和菲利斯在这时刻真的有着完美的化学反应。然后她告诉了所有人，并在整个办公区大厅当众羞辱了安吉拉·马丁。当她这么做时，我和她一样完全沉浸在情境中，我能感觉到皮肤发烫。就像我的脸开始发红一样。
Yeah. You can see it. Everyone is looking at you. Everyone, you know, and we've talked about whenever you had a scene where the whole bullpen focused on you, you were already heightened a little bit like your nerves. And I really just, oh man, I was, as the character, I felt like I couldn't get out of there fast enough. And then Andy walks in.
对。你能看出来。每个人都在看着你。每个人，你知道的，我们讨论过，每当你有全办公区的人都聚焦于你的戏时，你的情绪已经有点高度紧绷了，也就是你的神经。我真的只是，天哪，作为这个角色，我觉得我无法以足够快的速度离开那个地方。然后安迪走了进来。
I know. And the way Ed just, you know, Ed helms the person. His inherent goodness and sweetheart just carries through the character of Andy. I know. Well, here's the thing. Is Andy like completely annoying? Sure. Mm-hmm.
我知道。埃德那种方式，你知道，埃德·赫尔姆斯这个人。他与生俱来的善良和温柔在安迪这个角色身上展露无遗。我知道。好吧，事情是这样的。安迪是不是完全令人讨厌？确实。嗯哼。
But he's also got this boyish charm. Yeah. A boyish enthusiasm, right? Yes. For singing this song to you. Yes. And in the script, the song he sings is Silent Night. Oh, yes.
但他也有那种少年的魅力。对。一种少年的热情，对吧？是的。为你唱这首歌。是的。而在剧本中，他唱的歌是《平安夜》。哦，是的。
Mm-hmm. Randy said, the morning of the shoot, they told Ed, he was so scared to say it. He said, they've changed their mind. Can you do Deck the Halls? Ed had to learn a whole new song to play on the sitar. He had just learned Silent Night. Yes. He'd had that thing for a couple of weeks and he'd been fiddling around on it.
嗯哼。兰迪说，拍摄那天早上，他们告诉埃德，他吓得都不敢说。他说，他们改变主意了。你能弹《装饰大厅》吗？埃德不得不学一首全新的歌在西塔尔琴上演奏。他才刚学会《平安夜》。是的。他拿那个东西才两周左右，一直在上面拨弄。
And then they were like, can you do Deck the Halls? Randy told me it took him about a minute and a half to figure it out because he's amazing. Yeah. He's a musical genius. They thought it would be funny, the juxtaposition of this sort of very cringy moment for Andy to be playing this upbeat song. And you know, he improvised the Riddited to do at the end. I know.
然后他们就问，你能弹《装饰大厅》吗？兰迪告诉我，他花了一分半钟就摸透了，因为他太厉害了。是的。他是个音乐天才。他们觉得这会很有趣，安迪弹奏这首欢快的歌时那种非常尴尬的时刻的对比。你知道的，他在最后即兴发挥了“里迪特·多”。我知道。
So good. We're all just staring at him. And Ed played the moment so perfectly. My heart completely broke for Andy. I felt so bad for him and I started to cry. Like actually crying. Yeah. I actually cry.
太棒了。我们都只是盯着他看。而埃德把那个时刻把握得太完美了。我的心完全为安迪碎了。我为他感到难过，然后我开始哭。真的哭了。是的。我真的哭了。
If you look at this, it pushes in on my face and I'm completely tearing up. Those are those moments as an actor where you have so inhabited your character's story and the story of the people around you where your body, like you didn't even have to make yourself cry or think of something sad. You were just so in the moment that the emotions just flood. No. Really, really. And everyone was playing it so real.
如果你看这个，镜头推向我的脸，我完全在流泪。作为一名演员，有些时刻你已经完全融入了你角色的故事以及你身边人的故事，以至于你的身体，比如你甚至不需要让自己哭或者想一些悲伤的事情。你只是完全沉浸在当下，情绪就涌上来了。不。真的，真的。而且每个人都演得那么真实。
Paul Feig told us to. Like he said, when we come around with that B camera, and this was similar to his direction in Office Olympics, he said, I don't want you to comment on it with, you know, no kind of funny looks or anything. Like this is like truly a human moment. And just stand there. Just be in it. It was great direction.
保罗·菲格让我们这么做的。就像他说的那样，当我们用那个B摄像机转过来时，这和他在《办公室奥运会》里的指导类似，他说，我不想你们对此做任何评论，你知道的，不要有任何滑稽的表情之类的。就像这是一个真正的人性时刻。就站在那里。就身处其中。这是很棒的指导。
And you felt it. Yeah. You felt it. It felt heavy. It felt really heavy and I felt horrible and I started to cry. You know, in rewatching it all, I just thought this episode was written and directed and acted so, so well. I was really proud of us as a show.
你感受到了。是的。你感受到了。感觉很沉重。感觉真的非常沉重，我感到糟糕透了，然后我开始哭。你知道，在重看这一切时，我只是觉得这一集的编剧、导演和表演都太棒了。我为我们作为一部剧感到非常自豪。
You know what, Angela, this was what Paul Feig could do for us, you know, like he was really good at directing us to allow these moments to breathe. And you're so good in this. Oh, thanks, ladies. You're so good in this whole episode and this moment at the end, it is more powerful because it's real. Yeah. You really nailed it.
你知道吗，安吉拉，这就是保罗·菲格能为我们做到的，你知道的，他非常擅长指导我们让这些时刻得以呼吸。而且你在这集里表现得太棒了。哦，谢谢你们，女士们。你在整集里都表现得太棒了，特别是最后这个时刻，它更有力量，因为它很真实。是的。你真的演得太到位了。
Thanks so much, lady. Thank you. And I thought Kate Flannery crushed this episode too. Same. And you know, guys, the supporting cast, these moments were fewer and far between for us. And so when they happened, we just treasured it and it was so fun to rewatch it. And you guys would get these scripts with no notice and you'd have to just step up to the plate and suddenly carry an episode.
太感谢了，女士。谢谢。而且我觉得凯特·弗兰纳里在这集里也演得绝了。我也是。而且你们知道吗，配角们，这样的时刻对我们来说比较少。所以当它们发生时，我们只是倍加珍惜，重看这一集太有趣了。你们总是在毫无预警的情况下拿到剧本，然后不得不挺身而出，突然挑起一集的大梁。
And you always did it because we had a really great bench on our show. We had a deep bench, y'all. We did. Well, that is Moroccan Christmas. We did it. We did it. We all hope you'll have a little responsibility in your life. Yeah, and just want to give a few thank yous to Justin Spitzer, Aaron Shore, Halstead
而且你们总是能做到，因为我们的节目里有一支非常棒的替补阵容。我们有深厚的替补席，各位。确实如此。好吧，这就是《摩洛哥圣诞节》。我们做到了。我们做到了。我们都希望你们生活中能有点责任感。是的，还要对贾斯汀·斯皮策、亚伦·肖尔、霍尔斯特德
Sullivan, Jen Salata, Randy Cordray, and Stephen Sox. Remember, you can find Stephen and his wife, Lori, on their podcast if we knew then. And I know you traded a bunch of messages with Kate as well. Yes. Kate Flannery and James Carey because the script, having the shooting draft, was just amazing for this one. And before we go, one little tidbit. We're so excited to finally get to share with you.
沙利文、珍·萨拉塔、兰迪·科德雷和史蒂芬·索克斯表示感谢。记住，你可以在他们的播客《如果我们当时就知道》中找到史蒂芬和他的妻子洛里。而且我知道你也和凯特交流了很多信息。是的。凯特·弗兰纳里和詹姆斯·凯里，因为剧本，也就是拍摄底稿，对于这一集来说简直太棒了。在结束之前，还有一个小花絮。我们很高兴终于能与大家分享。
Yes. We're so excited to tell you guys that we have partnered with Comedy Central and Cartooner Radio to bring you animated clips of our podcast. Yes. You know, we're constantly getting mail from people saying they wish they could watch us on video. And for many reasons we won't get into now, we do not videotape our podcast, but Cartooner Radio has taken some of the audio and they have animated it, which in my opinion is even
是的。我们非常高兴地告诉大家，我们已经与喜剧中心和卡通广播公司合作，为大家带来我们播客的动画剪辑。是的。你知道的，我们经常收到人们的信件，说他们希望能看我们的视频。由于我们现在不便透露的许多原因，我们没有对播客进行录像，但卡通广播公司截取了一些音频并制作成了动画，依我看，这甚至比
better than watching a video. It is, you guys. They are so creative, Jen and I are now a cartoon. I love it. I love it. And they have picked these funny moments to animate. It's going to debut on Comedy Central's YouTube. We'll put it in our socials so you can find it.
看视频还要好。真的是这样，各位。他们太有创意了，珍和我现在成了动画人物。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。而且他们挑选了这些有趣的时刻制作成动画。它将在喜剧中心的YouTube上首播。我们会把它放在我们的社交平台上，这样你们就能找到了。
We can't wait for you to see it. It starts tomorrow. Woo-hoo! All right, guys. We will see you next week. The horn can pierce the sky. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我们迫不及待想让你们看到了。明天开始。噢呼！好了，各位。我们下周见。号角能够刺破苍穹。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要获取《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。